alt sieht das herzig aus er sollte jetzt
willkommen zu diesem video wie man heute
was richtig ist habt ihr mich darauf
hingewiesen dass ich das perfekte von
hollywood filmen einfach mal nachmachen
könnte und das mache ich jetzt auch ich
nehme effekte aus hollywood filmen an
denen hunderte oder sogar tausende leute
dann arbeiten und besucht die so cool
wie es geht ganz alleine nachzustellen
und zwar mache ich das mit expertentag
klinik sei ja gerade seit ein paar
wochen in den kinos ist und da gibt's
zwei effekte die besonders gerade finden
und zwar einmal diese legendäre ex mann
stand mit dem ixs vorne drauf lieber die
nach modellieren und dann gibt es ja
noch diesen geilen verquatschen wo die
auf ihre haut diese energie liste glüht
artikel was ich drauf gekriegt haben
finde ich sie richtig aus und dafür
brauchen wir gesichts tracking von
gesichts tracking ist das geilste
überhaupt wenn man aber dieses gitter
seht wie es auf dem gesicht drauf
gezeigt wäre dann man letztendlich alles
aufs gesicht drauf klatscht würde ich
wäre doch mal ein bisschen spaß muss
sein also vielleicht mache ich mir ein
mondgesicht auf mein eigenes gesicht
mobilisieren kriegen viel spaß mit dem
video
ich habe dafür dieses filmmaterial
gefilmt ich weiß auch nicht einfach auf
gebäck mit der erste schritt ist es ein
3d modell von meinem gesicht zu
erstellen und da habe ich mich erst mal
gedreht nach links nach rechts ein
bisschen nach oben und unten ich
verwende hier übrigens die software in
lluc studio und dafür das plugin face
bilder ja deswegen staatliche grad die
ganzen sachen rein und in 3d sieht das
ganze jetzt gerade so aus wie ein
standard 3d kopf und den könnte jetzt
mit einzelnen punkten hier auf meinem
gesicht anpassen und ihr seht dass es
gerade hier einem drei- bis viertausend
prozentigen zeitraffer ja es hat relativ
lange gedauert aber ich ziehe halt zum
beispiel die nase von 3d modell an meine
nase das auge an natürlich mein auge und
so weiter und so fort und das geht echt
viel schneller als das ganze selbst zu
modellieren und ist auch echt ziemlich
gut anschließend kann man dieses 3d
modell auch auf meinem gesicht drauf
treten das chatten an sich war nicht
ganz so flüssig wie ihr setzt hier seht
weil er musste man eigentlich alle fünf
frames ungefähr noch mal ein bisschen
hand anlegen und die einzelnen punkte
nochmals zurechtrücken und das hat doch
ziemlich lange gedauert das ergebnis
kann sich sehen lassen finde ich richtig
gut vor allem hier zum beispiel wie sich
sogar die augenbrauen
wenn man es hier so gut sieht hier seht
ihr noch mal das dazugehörige 3d modell
welches erstellt wurde dabei und da
können wir doch mal die textur von man
sich doch man sieht dass wenn wir das
jetzt über meinem gesicht laufen lassen
mit den 3d modell und der bewegung dann
sieht das ganze wirklich extrem gruselig
aus und ich muss mich dafür schon mal
entschuldigen bei allen leuten die das
jetzt sehen werden aber kann man kann
uns auch durch seine geräte text
ersetzen aber wir wollen ja diese
glühende reste die bei der jean david
villa zu machen erlauben wir uns erst
noch ein bisschen spaß mit der textur
weil die können mich auch in photoshop
ein bisschen bearbeiten
zum beispiel mit tönen guten kerl hier
nicht so es richtig sie mal kurz zu
recht auge kommt darüber
zack zack zack naja das also bruder
vegas schon drauf soll natürlich jetzt
nicht möglichst realistisch aussehen er
dafür wird müsse man sich noch mal mehr
zeit nehmen aber ich finde halt
das hätte ich auch hört ja natürlich
auch sagt lange und effektiver und warm
die nase ist bis fall dass sich das
völlig aus also genauso sehen meine
alpträume aus jetzt wisst ihr bescheid
dort gehören auch zeitlich noch einen
schritt weiter
also auf diesen text uhr können wir sie
eben nicht nur donald trump drauf
klatschen oder monte sondern auch diese
risse eben und wir können diese textur
nicht nur als bild auf das gesicht drauf
gehabt sondern auch als video
demnach arbeiten wir jetzt mal diese
persönlich und ich habe mir dafür jetzt
gerade mal so eine ist extra aus dem
internet runtergeladen und kann jetzt an
bord dieser einzelnen sich hieraus
maskieren und dann überall über das
gesicht verteilen
dagegen spricht auch eigentlich gar nix
aber man kann die risse auch komplett
selber generieren dass die eben genauso
sind wie man sie möchte ich hatte jetzt
nämlich gerne ein bisschen feiner risse
dafür gehe ich hier in after effects of
generieren und gewitter und dann kann
man eben hier bei dem gewitter
verschiedenste einstellungen treffen
jetzt voll viele und dann aus diesem
riss muster maskierten wir wieder hier
einzelne sachen raus verteilt die man
ganzen gesicht und so weiter und so fort
länderspiele und das ganze dann so also
ich finde eigentlich bei der verteilung
ja so ziemlich alles aus also ich hab
jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr gemacht und
wir hier
original sieht sind diese gestern nicht
einmal nur statisch sondern die wackeln
auch so ein bisschen rum die wabern so
ein bisschen die haben so ein bisschen
eine verzerrung die machen jetzt hier im
hintergrund gerade auch mit dem
turbulenten versetzen effekt und was
natürlich noch wichtig ist ist das ganze
in uns ein bisschen glück dass es so
leuchtet wie hier im original und das
mache ich dadurch dass ich an bord die
sehr witzige kopier und die kopie davon
einfach unscharf zeigen und dann hat es
hier so ein schein und damit sich diese
risse noch mehr verändern habe ich ja
schon fragt halles rauschen generiert
welches sich als alpha maske benutzer ja
leute damit das ganze eben so hin und
her wandert und es jetzt bin ich
ziemlich geil aus wie so ein kleines
elektro gewitter und das lege ich jetzt
hier auf mein gesicht drauf und zwar so
dass ich den hintergrund schwarz machte
um angesichts auch damit ich quasi nur
eine schwarz-weiß ebene bekommen mit den
weißen blitzen damit ich das quasi
später übers feld einmal darüber legen
kann und dann mach ich das nochmal extra
mit der verschwommenen version ja das
glühend damit ich das glühen quasi noch
mal unabhängig von den anderen anpassen
kann ein bisschen stärker machen kann
und so weiter und so fort
jetzt stelle ich meist wenn die farben
um und zwar diese liste haben so ein
leicht helles orange und dieses glühen
ja deshalb so ein rot bis helping
irgendwie hab ich habe schnell
festgestellt dass eine einzelne fall
nicht gut aus die das gericht jetzt ein
kleines muster schaffen dass es so ein
bisschen rötlich orange lich ist und
jetzt schon nice aus und jetzt noch das
film hat gerade ein bisschen dunkler
damit das glühen noch ein bisschen
besser zum vorschein kommt und nachher
nochmal ein paar kollegen verkauft aber
doch so richtig schön rein gebrannt
aussieht und dadurch das finde ich die
stöße aus was natürlich jetzt gar nicht
fehlen darf ist die bewegungsunschärfe
die nachricht über alles drauf ich habe
das video nämlich auch mal mit ziemlich
hohen vater spielt gefilmt damit ich
eben diese ganzen details ab und damit
im video keine bewegungsunschärfe trend
ist einfach damit ich mehr details ab
für das drücken damit es besser läuft
aber im fertigen video wollen wir das
natürlich nicht da wollen wir
bewegungsunschärfen deswegen habe ich
das auf alles gleichzeitig drauf und
zwar auf die risse und auf meine haut
und ihr seht was hier das passt perfekt
rein und gibt dem ganzen natürlich
nochmal vier realistischeren look und
wenn man das jetzt mit dem original
vergleich mit der gene finde ich ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich neues klar man kann sich
immer noch mehr zeit geben aber an sich
bin ich das hier ziemlich geil ich finds
nur im nachhinein bisschen schade dass
ich mich so viel bewegt habe
deswegen sieht man dieses fahrbahn und
das backen und dieses verschwimmen
dieser einzelnen risse nicht so gut aber
nichtsdestotrotz bin ich sehr sehr happy
damit es ist so geil ich liebe es wir
haben wir dieses gitter auf der haut
drauf klebt und man
defekte drauf balkan fahren wir mit dem
motto richtig notwendig machen wir mal
nicht so mit der stadt will die ich erst
mal modellieren muss ok auch zum
stalltür schott der legende und das wie
gesagt werde ich 3d modellieren und das
möglichst gut zu machen wir jetzt mal
eine vorlage und die vorlage hier im
video ist ein bisschen verzerrt das
mache ich jetzt meine objektiv krümmung
korrektur drauf und stellt er dann auch
nochmal perspektivisch das eben perfekt
passt und ich das projekt als vorlage in
meinem 3d programm verwenden kann und
leute ich war so frustriert weil ich hab
das ganze einfach dreimal gemacht und am
ende ist es immer abgepackt und ich habe
zwar gespeichert aber dieser teilweise
komplett lehrt deswegen musste ich
wirklich dreimal machen beim dritten mal
da also da auf jeden fall war der erste
schritt im 3d programm dass ich quasi
erst mal die kamera an die kamera aus
dem schott anpasse und das habe ich
gemacht indem ich so einen würfel
erstellt hat den habe ich quasi genau
die richtigen perspektive punkte gesetzt
habe ich bei der kamera ist meine
richtige brennweite eingestellt und dann
habe ich die kamera so weit hin und her
bewegt bis eben die linien des würfels
gleicher jahr diesen raum darstellt mit
den linien des raums im bild
übereinstimmen dann hier die platte
links hatte rechts platte unten platte
oben
das kann man relativ gut jetzt machen da
die perspektive stimmt deswegen kann ich
die objekte auch einfach so an euren weg
hier im bild aufsehen an der hinteren
platte kann man sich nicht erklären wie
man so 3d modelliert und zwar habe ich
dafür einfach eine 2 die ebene erstellt
und in dieser zweite ebeling die
entsprechenden teile nach hinten
reingedrückt die dann eben diese kerbe
hier darstellen
bei der tour habe ich angefangen mit
einem ganz einfachen zylinder aus dem
ich dann quasi das innere
rausgeschnitten habe so dass ich nur
diesen äußeren rahmen habe und dann
quasi auch nur die vorderseite des
zylinders genommen habe also nicht in 3d
zylinder an sich dann wird nur die
vorderseite und den zylinder dann nach
hinten einfach gestreckt habe um wieder
in voluminösen körper zu haben
und so sieht dann der erste test länder
aus ja es sieht noch gar nicht aus wie
einen fertigen bild dafür fehlen noch
alles das muss ich noch mal die einzel
materialien so verändern dass es eben
reflektion gibt und dass die reflektion
eben nicht komplett perfekt sind so ein
bisschen verschwommen und das ist
material ebenso ein bisschen bläulichen
schimmer hat und ganz wichtig war auch
dass die tür also dieser rahmen der tür
diese runde dass deren anderes material
hat als der rest aber dass der rest
eigentlich so ziemlich das gleiche
material hatte und dann gibt es einfach
nur sehr sehr viele test ränder die
ein bisschen zu hellen bis zu dunkeln
bisschen viel zu helfen und so geht das
dann weiter bis sie dann den finalen
ränder sieht und dieser finale ränder
hat in echt einfach über 20 minuten
gedauert das ganze gerade 6000
vorgespult dementsprechend tut mir das
auch wirklich leider in der stelle weil
ursprünglich wollte ich das ganze
animieren aber können jetzt vorstellen
wenn da ein einziges bild 20 minuten
dauert dann dauert zehn stunden um auch
nur eine sekunde animationen rauszuhören
dann an der stelle aber ich glaube dass
familien ist und bisher in jeder
verzeihen ich bin ziemlich zufrieden was
jetzt noch fehlt ist die farbkorrektur
deswegen ziehe ich das ganze noch mal
nachgefragt so mache jetzt quasi mit
einer rgb kurve noch mal den kontrast
schön das ist ja ein bisschen besser dem
original video passt und stellt auch die
farben 1 nicht so deutlich bläulich und
ein bisschen lieder und ich finde so
kann sich das ganze sehen lassen ja die
reflexion bei der tür sind ein bisschen
anders hat man die lichter ein bisschen
anders setzen können aber im großen und
ganzen ich das ziemlich neu ist jetzt
quasi der vergleich zwischen dem was ich
gemacht habe und dem wie es im film war
und das heute sagen leute ich finde es
ziemlich neues aber schade dass ich
nicht animieren konnte so viel zu
starten wenn ihr jetzt auch kreativ
werden möchte dann kann ich mir schon
viel mal einen schnittkurs abzuchecken
da habe ich in möglichst kurzer zeit
möglichst gut strukturiert möglichst
viel wissen verpackt damit er möglichst
schnell möglichst kleine sachen
schneiden lernen könnt jetzt gerade gibt
es noch bis montagabend mit dem coach
von arsenal 25 prozent rabatt also
checkt man den link in der beschreibung
abgang abonnement und ihr könnt euch das
ganze so oft angucken wie ihr möchtet
also abchecken wenn ihr noch idee hat
für welchen film welches auch machen
könnte das defekte dach macht dann
schreiten wir es in die kommentare
und wenn du dich auf dieser reise
begleiten sollte dann abonniert gerne
diesen kanal
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder etwas
gutes
[Musik]